اذا مشاهدينا ميدانيا تطور لافت ومقلق
بالنسبه لموسكو حيث اعلن المتحدث باسم
الكريم
بان مجموعه تخريبيه دخلت منطقه بلغورد
الروسيه على الحدود الاوكرانيه الروسيه
واعتبر ان الهجوم يهدف الى تحويل الانتباه
عن احتلال اوكرانيا وايضا
كما نشاهد هنا على هذه الخارطه
هذه هي المنطقه التي اتحدث عنها اذا بهذه
بالعوده الى هذه النقطه
اذا هذه
المحاوله او الاختراق يعتبر تطور لافت
يعني مساق الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه حيث
اضاف بسكوب بان وزاره الدفاع وجهاز الامن
الفيدرالي وحرس الحدود يتخذون كل التدابير
الضروريه للقضاء على المخربين هنا
مشاهدينا بحسب المعلومات الاوليه فان
المسؤولين عن الحادث ينتمون لجماعات قوميه
روسيه تقاتل في اوكرانيا هما فيلق الحريه
الروسي وفيلق المتطوعين الروسي هنا ايضا
للتذكير بان هذه الجماعات هي جماعات قوميه
متطرفه بحسب طبعا روسيا سلط الضوء عليها
بدايه الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه تطم تضم
طبعا متطوعين كانوا يقاتلون الى جانب
الجيش الاوكراني في بخموت وقتلوا بشراسه
وينتشرون طبعا في دومباس وهم اليوم بحسب
القوات الروسيه مسؤولين عن هذا الهجوم في
مدينه بلغرت
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات